this isn't a lottery draw the winners
will receive an unconditional basic
income this is going to travel this will
make a big change in this life 1000
euros a month for a whole year and you
don't have to do a thing for it a Berlin
not-for-profit group has already handed
out 12-month basic incomes to 53 people
the concept may seem utopian but it's
actually an economic necessity
today's welfare state was developed in
the Industrial Age now we're in the
digital age working conditions have
changed jobs are no longer secure and
there's no long-term employment these
days so I believe that the proper
response is to provide people with a
basic income Nisha bo Meyer is the
group's founder and his proposal is
revolutionary he wants to provide people
with a measure of financial security
people can enjoy life more in this
timeframe because they won't have to
worry about how they're going to pay the
bills it's because I'm fatter spyin
mention it have no overall positive
effect we have three people who are now
self-employed one person quit his job at
a call center and he's now taking
courses in teaching several of our
people are taking advanced education
courses this program changes the way you
think about life the changes the way you
deal with other people because you no
longer have to compete with them deal
with them as equals but many economists
are skeptical professor Dominic ensta
has been studying the concept of basic
guaranteed income for eight years he
says it's a fine idea in principle but
it's not viable income the skate-a-thon
becomes the siphon is accepted okay as
you gain effect income can provide
motivation it inspires people to set
goals and work toward them other people
can qualify for a fairly high guaranteed
income
without having to work for it it will
suck their motivation to work thing that
will make it difficult to fill a lot of
jobs and provide services that most
people don't want to do the evenness of
fish bass mutton Catrin plink has worked
for most of her adult life she's a
freelance graphic artist she doesn't
earn much six months ago she won a basic
income
she used the extra cash to complete a
correspondence course and now she works
as a health management instructor
that's with my lead I laughed face it's
really changed my life for the better I
can make plans and decide how best to
invest my time I can get out of the
daily grind and start new projects nice
the project it's a new step in in new
directions button for militant
annihilation
the basic income project is financed by
crowdfunding people can make donations
however small by going to a website
anyone can sign up for the lottery style
draw no pain is required but what a
program like this actually work on a
national scale
we'd have to reallocate some resources
and we'd probably have to raise taxes
but you'd also be able to get rid of a
lot of programs like unemployment
benefits student loans and child welfare
bureaucracy that goes with them you can
try it with a consumer types of 50% but
you'd also have to stop people from
working illegally and make sure they
don't evade paying taxes when can you
try to exclude people who come here to
Germany just to get the basic income but
I can't think of a single study that
says that such a program could be
adequately funded but these people
believe in what they're doing more than
170,000 people took part in the last
draw and nine of them will be able to
enjoy a basic guaranteed income for the
next 12 months